all right your most accurate weather now
forecast sherry's off today
sun got up just after six beautiful
pictures here but you got to remember it
is already warm
we didn't even get to like 90 so far at
mccarran but let's find out what's going
on in your neighborhood oh it's cooler
aliante you're at 82 again best time of
day for walking the dog
or getting your jog in or whatever but
you still have to watch out for some
smoke in the air from the california
wildfires 87 for seven hills 88 at
mountains edge henderson you are at 91
and was 110 degrees at four o'clock this
morning
death valley now at 107 just under
triple digits for laughlin
so we talked about the number of days in
a row with a high
at or above 110 degrees so there's a
statistic for this for weather nerds
the record for a number of days in a row
with a high at or above 110
10 days in a row back in june of 1961.
now there have been several instances
where there were nine days in a row with
a high adder above 110
so far in august of 2020 we're at five
days we'll certainly do it again today
we will keep track on whether or not we
get that far as if you really care about
all of that
so we're going for a high of 113 today
we did 112 yesterday
this will be a record high beating the
111 that is currently the record
we also have to watch for monsoon there
could be some storm clouds bubbling up
over the higher elevations for your
family and friends here's what's going
on
some storms in the midwest now the high
temperature the current temperatures
that is denver's at 70.
oklahoma city is at 71. let's get your
seven-day forecast in here
so 113 again tomorrow that'll bust a
record 112 for thursday
we may slip to 110 for friday but that
could be the end of our number of days
in a row with a high at or above
110.